hi guys hi crack huh John today we're
going to watch Sean Spicer
press-conference cold-open the dirty
white boy
no the one that was recently not the
first one then Melissa McCarthy's the
one I saw yeah it is the second one this
is hysterical Melissa McCarthy's
impression of Sean Spicer I have never
paid more attention to politics than now
okay yeah at least a little clips I've
seen from recent us analysis like
they're really throwing out going
full-bore on this political kali i want
to give you guys a heads up that I'm
actually moving apartments right now
last day is tomorrow for me then I move
one Wednesday so I might not be able to
upload videos again for another couple
days so something huge dropped you don't
see a video for it I'm not being lazy I
just probably don't have everything set
up yet to go yep
please be understanding some of you
pricks out there we now go live to the
daily White House press briefing with
press secretary
[Applause]
Hey
[Applause]
all right first of all I'd just like to
doubt that I'm calm now and I will
remain calm as long as you start them
I'm not going to do that because that's
the old spicy and this is the new spicy
and I have been told that I must have
cut back on the guns chewing so I am now
limiting might just one slice I'll get
back to you later
now I'd like to begin with the
president's schedule 3 p.m.
president Trump is going to meet with
the leader from Central Asia shops the
president loves my back automatically to
maybe discuss the unrest in Kakaako to
haggis and specifically
so right there you're right his wife
[Music]
Connie okay get that now I'm going to
open it up for questions and I'm going
to probably bridge if you start asking
stupid one speaking about priest and
stupid one Glen Rock New York Times look
I just wanted to know what the president
tends to do now that the appeals court
denied your request that's not the
travel ban you're asking me big guys
simple if the appeals court won't do
what's right president Trump will see
them in court specifically the people he
Haiti Flanagan such cases are real some
rulings are final don't f with me
clarify this turkey the president has
said there should be a test the
immigrants truly love America what would
that test even be ah it's easy its
extreme Betty it screamed Betty but what
does that mean
extreme venting what does it mean it
means it's extreme you know what
place you can explain so you jump babies
can understand your side efficacious my
big worm you already used my galley
here's how it's gonna go down you've got
your TSA agent right here okay and Bert
you got Barbie coming in nice American
girl back from a dream vacation we know
she's okay because she's blonde we
understand that perfect now who's up
next
Oh slow your roll honey and then we're
going to Pat her down and then we're
going to read our emails and if we don't
like the answers which we won't
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes earlier this week you said there was
a terrorist attack in Atlanta yes I said
that wrong when I said it and then you
wrote it which makes you wrong say
something wrong you guys should know
what it is I'm meeting wrong right
you're wrong and that's why you're here
obviously I meant Orlan top Orlando you
know what okay look the problem is all
these terrorists introspect into the
tenants it is that you're not reporting
on okay it will hold your back see you
guys never even write about never
covered in one let's read from the list
okay the Bowling Green massacre okay
cariann want the real one
okay the horror exit flag the slaughter
at Fraggle Rock they drove Old Dixie
down okay and then there's some like
terrorism this week when North strong
[Music]
and especially okay and that's
Nordstrom's law because these are high
high quality products in fact I'm
wearing one of her bangles it's
beautiful it's shimmery is elegant and
at the brand-new Learning Channel and
everyone was very excited about him
and he's going to answer some questions
as well as here we've all sales we're
here
they are fence the base around them on
Automotion lose the law k-member not the
public by saying my friend Mitch
McConnell still feeling like an
alligator bite a head off whole thing
felt like a nice and special oh we all
hold a few pounds brown regular and
black Thank You secretary second you
know we do need someone who's going to
bring back law and order because places
like Chicago the murder rate is over 80%
percent of the people in Chicago have
been murdered and that's young you you
did that yeah you know what I'm looking
at the real numbers here and they
directly contradict everything
[Music]
[Applause]
you know what that was me pulling away
there miss on it
any other questions yeah just mentally
though are you okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's so scary gosh the way sure making
fun of real things he says yeah hold up
administration like the murder rate the
numbers I heard from you were just
ridiculous everything everything's added
another addition a terrorist attacks
[ __ ] and every constant blame towards
the media take no responsibility for
anything we are right all of it is
correct so much contradiction and so
much love it's sounding worst most
disorganized landing it's a reality show
it is we love bad behaviors whether
somebody thinks pieces about ownership
and John Spicer did not like this
impression I know
Trump said that it was insulting that it
made something like this it was mean
there's been NGS that was mean and
Trump's of that because it's a woman it
makes them look weak yeah it works it
just isn't what the general indicate we
kill a budget all I would ever feel
doesn't fire go for it make one of the
black without we're not a political
channel but this is this is the most in
our life that John and I've ever talked
about politics
yeah we've always never just gotten
together to hang out and had politics
come up a conversation and then like
lately yeah you know once every few days
we'll just throw it out on Dixie only
it's terrifying but entertaining what's
going on right now with our presidency
because not just trumpets everywhere the
whole administration is a bunch of
frauds and liars
yes ridiculous all those people he said
he was gonna take out of the guy yeah we
totally different points of view math oh
yeah I mean it's the first time I might
truly like royalty like follow every day
I'm like learning more and more and more
bring up tonight really popping up to
date but he just doesn't stop getting
ridiculous what he says and does burst
it was just shrimp did he get killing a
Conway then you get Spicer like you get
is what you get my general that you get
my fancy yes my head get this is just
like what do you got a whole cast of
weird ass characters now great show real
life lately has become like being the
rest of the country during a shitty
version of The West Wing I just know
this [ __ ] you don't if you didn't see
all the behind the scenes that you just
thought from the people's perspective
this is does that shown as hysterical
but yeah I love Melissa McCarthy's
impression to Sean Spicer I wonder how
they do because it seems like it doesn't
look like she's reading a ton of this
stuff like now it looks like I'm
remembers it
yeah or you know even if there are like
bullet points she's motivated seems like
there's a lot of ad-libbing like she
seems really comfortable and a Natalie
invested in the timing of the physical
dislike I went to pull out stuff I even
with was a Khalif blower yeah cuz I
remember the first like anytime that
something came out it was brilliant and
I love how they cuz they should get used
to in the first sketchy like take off
the podium or running in a wow this is
like automatic on wheels do these call
opens of a fun dynamic because like the
Alec Baldwin Trump sketches are funny
and those are like sort of you know
zingers every second this has that like
buildup of like I know every time
something happens I know something else
is coming and I don't know what and
where it's gonna come from I just know
it's going to be outlandish it's made
for some of SNL best material its
president but yeah they seemed like I
said I saw like a full episode from last
week or whatever they're really throwing
down yeah well the vault does a lot of
political sketches and I would say I
mean there's work they're making more
captivating TV and I have the best years
alright guys well SNL has a channel
where they tend to put their best
sketches up of that episode
use your babel sketches you don't really
give a [ __ ] about these watch the ones
that were considered best of that
episode and they put those up online so
can you go subscribe to their channel
dude Katelyn kidding though so I forgot
which hurt her impression of him that
that like deep down southern accent like
yeah
she's in like that's what I'm excited
for she played in general she's played
Hillary Clinton Hillary Clinton was is
Warren she's played Kelley and calm wick
yeah I think he played Kelly Nicole I
think I was a sketch yeah I think this
episode
it's like Kelly and Conway trying to
like seduce her way back on the team
nothing like it is [ __ ] scary dude
subscribe to the real rejects jhanas
reason to Gerry on Twitter and Instagram
he's a social media manager of Blum
house and the real rejects and shout out
to all the funny obese woman thanks guys
that's not how I would worry but yeah
shoutouts to yalter all over you some
fat is expensive I
[Music]